Brigadier General Patrick S Ryder at the
Pentagon tap and then we'll get right to
your questions so first of all to add to
information already provided earlier by
the White House at the direction of the
president of the United States fighter
aircraft assigned to U.S Northern
command successfully took down a high
altitude Airborne object off the
northern coast of Alaska at 1 45 PM
eastern standard time today within U.S
Sovereign airspace over U.S territorial
water
on February 9 North American Aerospace
Defense command detected an object on
ground radar and further investigated
and identified the object using fighter
aircraft
the object was flying at an altitude of
forty thousand feet and posed a
reasonable threat to the safety of
Civilian flight
U.S Northern command is beginning
recovery operations now
U.S northern command's Alaska command
coordinated the operation with
assistance from the Alaska Air National
Guard
Federal Aviation Administration and the
Federal Bureau of Investigation
we have no further details about the
object at this time including any
description of its capabilities purpose
or origin the object was about the size
of a small car so not similar in size or
shape to the High Altitude surveillance
balloon that was taken down off the
coast of South Carolina on February 4.